hey guys it is tuesday and i am just and
not to marry no doubt disappointing many
of you but i was off adventuring
yesterday and I'm literally in pain
everywhere my buddy so hopefully that
cushions the blow a little bit like top
gaming you nerd leaks has uncovered and
Instagram post which looks very much
like it could be showing off the
protagonist of watchdogs tears King a
performance artist posted the photo with
the caption had a blast doing motion
capture work as the lead actor in a new
video game series the account is now
private but the image features a man of
Asian descent to wearing a baseball cap
and a bandana covering his mouth he also
sports a messenger bag while holding a
gun in one hand and a phone in the other
which is pretty standard Aiden Pearce
behavior Ubisoft has confirmed watchdogs
to is in development but they have not
released any further details as yet and
the image appears to be a work in
progress character render next up Sega
have officially announced dawn of war
three the latest entry in relic
entertainment Warhammer 40k series sega
released a trailer that shows the
ongoing war between the space marines
and aux in what appears to be a larger
scale than in previous games the trailer
also features the elder race relic is
introducing the imperial nuts and write
notes to the series which they've called
their biggest units ever sega have said
that dawn of war 3 combines the epic
scale of dawn of war with the
customization and elite heroes of dawn
of war two no launch date has been
specified as yet and the game is
expected to arrive on PC Bethesda has
announced to that Dishonored 2 will come
to xbox one ps4 and PC on November 11
the world premiere of dishonor tooth
gameplay will take place during
Bethesda's III showcase but they'll be
streaming it so you won't miss out the
game's description reads will you make
your way through the game unseen make
full use of its original combat system
or use a blend of both how will you
combine your characters unique set of
powers or weapons and gadgets to
make your enemies the story responds to
your choices leading to intriguing
outcomes as you play through each of the
games handcrafted missions just honored
to will let you up to play as either
corvo attano or Emily called wins over
whom have different powers and weapons
the game is set in the new region of
konica the place where Corvo was born
and is also the source of the bone
charms from the first games and we need
an e in that comment section if you're
keen for this one of two and be sure to
head to games but cool we've got stories
on the overwatch beta and dooms PS
quarter of these that is everything I
have for you today i'll be sure to make
a video letting you know what the hell
happened yesterday and i will see you
tomorrow thanks for watching